hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 21 hört zu und spricht nach
im januar ist winter im januar ist
winter im februar ist es kalt im februar
ist es kalt im april ist frühling
im april ist frühling im mai blühen die
blumen blühen die blumen im juli ist
sommer im juli ist sommer im august ist
es heiss im august ist es heiss im
oktober ist herbst
ist herbst im november regnet es oft im
november regnet es oft am ersten august
ist der nationalfeiertag der schweiz am
ersten august ist der nationalfeiertag
der schweiz am 2
september habe ich geburtstag
september habe ich geburtstag am dritten
juli fliege ich in die ferien am dritten
juli fliege ich in die ferien am vierten
märz mache ich eine party am vierten
märz mache ich eine party am 15 januar
habe ich frei
am 15 januar habe ich frei
mein termin ist am 6 februar ein termin
ist am 6 februar
am 11 november beginnt die fasnacht am
elften november beginnt die fasnacht am
14 mai ist das fußballspiel am 14
mai ist das fußballspiel am 21 juni ist
der längste tag vom jahr am 21 juni ist
der längste tag vom jahr
am 31 dezember ist silvester am 31
dezember ist silvester
hast du kinder
ja ich habe
ja ich habe einen sohn
ja ich habe eine tochter
ja ich habe zwei söhne
ja ich habe zwei töchter
nein ich habe keine kinder
nein ich habe keine kinder hast du
geschwister hast du geschwister
ja ich habe einen bruder
ja ich habe eine schwester
ja ich habe zwei brüder
ja ich habe zwei schwestern
nein ich bin ein einzelkind
bist du verheiratet bist du verheiratet
ja ich bin verheiratet
nein ich bin nicht verheiratet
nein ich bin ledig nein ich bin ledig
nein ich bin geschieden
hast du einen freund hast du einen
freund
ja ich habe einen freund ja ich habe
einen freund
nein ich habe keinen freund
hast du eine frau
hast du eine freundin
ja ich habe eine freundin
nein ich habe keine freundin
am ersten august feiern die schweizer
ihren nationalfeiertag
dann ist in der schweiz sommer viele
leute grillieren und hängen fahnen auf
in der nacht zünden sie feuerwerk
die unabhängigkeit den rütlischwur und
die gründung der eidgenossenschaft 1291
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg hat es in
italien am 2 juni 1946 eine
volksabstimmung zur einführung der
republik gegeben seither feiert italien
am 2 juni den nationalfeiertag 1903 am
dritten november hat sich panama von
gross kolumbien losgelöst panama feiert
am dritten november den nationalfeiertag
am 4
februar 1948 hat sich sri lanka von
großbritannien für unabhängig erklärt
sri lanka feiert am 4
februar den nationalfeiertag am 5
dezember feiert thailand den
nationalfeiertag
sie feiern den geburtstag von könig
bhumibol adulyadej 1927 brasilien feiert
am 17 september den nationalfeiertag
es ist der tag der unabhängigkeit von
portugal am 7 september 1822 frankreich
feiert am 14 juli den nationalfeiertag
die franzosen feiern den sturm auf die
bastille 1789 während der französischen
revolution
mexiko feiert am 16
september den nationalfeiertag die
mexikaner feiern die loslösung von
spanien am 16 september 1810
indonesien feiert am 17 august den
nationalfeiertag die indonesia wurden am
17 august 1945 unabhängig australien
feiert am 26
januar den nationalfeiertag am 26 januar
1788 sind die ersten europäischen
siedler in australien eingetroffen
erst am 27 april 19 94 hat es die ersten
freien wahlen in südafrika gegeben
südafrika feiert deshalb am 27 april den
nationalfeiertag
die türkei feiert am 29
oktober den nationalfeiertag am 29
oktober 1923 wurde die republik türkei
als nachfolgestaat des osmanischen
reiches ausgerufen